[Music]
in animal lover news da who doesn't love
animal I love animals submitted by
bounced check that's unfortunate
a woman gave up a six-figure salary to
raise special needs goats
there's [ __ ] goats out there you
can't say that but oh yeah I am I can't
say that go to [ __ ] you can't say
the word really I thought it was just
for human think you can just for humans
can use yeah I'm not saying it insulting
them woke you know
yeah well I'm walk the opposite
direction all right I'm just broke okay
so was this lady now I'm socially broke
where's the R word only for humans or it
could be friends I honestly don't know
that's that's the PC police what do you
say what do you see principal please and
also the F word too cuz I'm miss using
it but if you can call goats like [ __ ]
goats I would love that
if we could get clarification on [ __ ]
goats that would be really no right or
wrong when are we gonna get back to like
South Park 1999 era yeah it's still
pretty crazy it's the best pretty crazy
but I feel like they don't say like that
like f-word they don't know and they I
don't think they see say dairy without
the are either what's good oh yeah yeah
like they changed there's Christmas
carols with Gary without the Arnon but
it's done in a good way yeah I mean I
think they still push boundaries but I
feel like it's gotten to be more like PC
so we're talking about this woman here
named Leanne she had a cushy six-figure
job as a corporate event planner in New
York and Manhattan that sounds like a
fun job [ __ ] your corporate event
planner yeah it sounds like you work for
like a stuffy company but you could use
the fun [ __ ] you get the plan can't see
any edits for Western Digital I'm just
planning example
and I'm like I want to do a karate class
for bonding you know or whatever it's
like you imagined all your
pencil-pushing co-workers doing that
that's how you did you plant ICA's one
year yeah cuz I was dope it was really
dope yeah good job maybe you're good at
it you want her job six figures no no no
I'm good yeah I'll do it
I'll have the Bombers parties yes rowdy
you wouldn't actually cuz your idea for
your your idea for your weddings really
good that's my my that's just his idea
is it karate wedding yeah I don't know
if he can say can you say well she she
was brainstorming like wedding ideas cuz
after we went to her friend's wedding
and it was like we went to a couple
weddings that year and it was like oh
you know there's like a format to this
stuff like it's like the ceremony the
reception well that really it's a new
tradition it's not like a hundred plus
years old though you know the way we
celebrated today so she's like you know
it's it's so been there done that right
and people obviously in the audience are
kind of bored so it's like why don't we
make something where everyone can
celebrate and I'm like what do you what
were you thinking and she's like well
imagine if we had like a convention
space in Vegas or whatever right and you
theme it and it's a big party in a
ceremony for every theme it's it could
just change and then it's kind of like a
whole entire show that everyone is
involved in so it could be like a pirate
theme or a 50s theme and then and for
every I guess like phase of what's going
on like the celebration it's it's like
you will bring out the costume from like
a like a prop place and everyone gets to
like put on the clothes and then like be
like now it's gonna be like you know
rockabilly style or whatever and then
have a band there or whatever and I'm
like that's insane but I like the idea
cuz then it's not so much Hey look at me
and how [ __ ] special I am and it's my
day it's more like yo this love is also
shared with the group and people like we
all spent so much time together you guys
helped us out with the relationship and
let's celebrate it together and no one
will be bored out of their ass and they
would actually thoroughly enjoy that
maldo
so I'm like that's awesome oh right yeah
and it's very unique so I was like
that's cool
like the attentional involved yeah yeah
but she didn't like the attention so
that's the main part like the main
reason why she don't want to be in front
of the stage why rose-color [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] hot and boring
okay so I'll show you guys so now she
has this mess ha
dude that that goat is a happy ask oh
what a photogenic goat very that was
smiling you show you guys this video
clip oh my god I want to go but these
aren't just any goats this is a
sanctuary for 85 goats with special
needs
Oh their handicap goes next show sons of
anarchy oh cool
Leeanne Laura Sela found at the farm
four years ago after leaving her cushy
six wait what about Sons of Anarchy my
friends and family you know how silly
they were and how smart they are and so
I started an Instagram account as a joke
I love goats anarchy it tastes really
good
but they're cute - oh baby gods are
[ __ ] adorable dude snag when one goat
got spooked by our camera crew its
season it's a narcolepsy goal no it's a
narcolepsy go and I think when they get
too scared they face oh I'll be play it
like play dead kind of I don't think
play dead I think they just just freak
out yeah so you can't really tell me
just one like four stacks of hay that
just like Oh - if you scare them too
much they can die of a heart attack
goats are so you know how I watch for
farm videos right yes when they
recommend if you're a first-time like
farmer for livestock they recommend
against goats because they're really
funny but they're like a handful because
they're like problematic they're trouble
or curious they try different [ __ ]
but they say like there there's always
never like there it's never a boring
time with goats because they're doing
something funny and hilarious
is every single day mm-hmm that's what
made me want to get goes beside fainting
have you seen all these uh clips of
goats like like ramming like little kids
like that
like they're very uh what do you call it
they goof around a lot like they play
all the time so they do funny things
like I guess it's one of those things
like if you don't have the animal I'm
pretty sure you won't really know like
the inside stuff about like cats that
you know or you know dogs that we know
it's like oh [ __ ] yeah that's so funny
man yeah
are they the ones that also climb trees
there are some goat yeah yeah yeah I
think I've seen a photo climbing goat
the ones I like seeing are the ones on
the cliffs and they're like standing on
this little rock against the cliff and
they're just like chillin I'm like Oh
grams goes ibex is those are dope it was
like how did you get up there you do
need some help
they're like bouldering yeah and I was
gonna say like I like I feel like uh I
hope that I can pull a move like this at
some point in my life where I'm like you
know what I'm kind of out and I just
want a farm life cuz I that's Joe's
dream really yeah we're here Hawaii here
Texas wherever they'll be fun I have a
friend that kind of has my dream where
it's kind of like this and also Jolin
kind a her dream and our dream all put
together so he just live in all of our
dreams out which is pretty cool so he's
a former really really high-level Navy
SEAL he's retired and then so now what
he does is he trains
he's a strength and conditioning coach
for UFC and like other NFL like pro
athletes and stuff so what he has is he
has this hundred acre ranch in Colorado
where he gets to like have all these
athletes economy test them and trains
them and stuff and he also dug out his
own Olympic sized pool there so it's
like a 50 meter whatever pool and so all
he does is because he's invited me over
he goes dude if you come over we'll get
high as [ __ ] and we'll talk about random
[ __ ] and we'll go ride around on my quad
and
whatever [ __ ] that pops up on our ranch
and we'll worked out that sounds so fun
yeah sounds [ __ ] it goes won't do DMT
and we'll [ __ ] trip balls and we'll
[ __ ] jump in the pool
it took me 1 ATV ride around like this
ranch for me to be like ok I'm a farm
boy now this is what I want to be what I
want to do just so much freedom I wasn't
saving up to buy property could be one a
fruit farm on Maui and make it a family
heirloom so that's that's a Dow pass it
down yeah that's one of our goals Nikki
wants to have an entire floor of our
house be dedicated to fostering kittens
and cats there's gonna smell like [ __ ]
yeah I know that's why it'll be a whole
floor so you got like a 3/3 floor 3
storey house we saw a very large house
can you call it cat farm we can't I
accept that name cat sanctuary but I
guess Beth's turned Howard turns wife
does that and Nikki follows her and
Instagram and she's just falling in love
with Ted that ideal someday Oh dog
sanctuary they could come over and have
a playdate
there you go they catch a sitter dog
farm yeah lofty as goals I just want a
[ __ ] movie theater in my [ __ ]
house
it's very doing with the Vegas or
something there's no saying yes we did
gotta move to Vegas and Sam is so down
it's a mob there it's not that good but
what they're mine oh but they got movie
theaters inside the houses but we what
about the mud we're over the land oh I
see right oh my god dude sorry okay and
I want to build a hut I guess it's Maui
then yeah we do dude you can [ __ ]
ship mud in you'll be saving so much
money on property taxes all the little
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] mud I guess you're
right but then but the weather's bad I
rather do Texas if I had to choose
between Las Vegas and then but my real
thing is the magic of Las Vegas will be
wiped away that's what scares me
it's [ __ ] love they need to that's
scary like when I go there I do not see
the drunk girl barefoot puking I do not
want to but if I'm laughing
right I don't see the homeless people
that go under the [ __ ] buildings and
survive and like they don't you know
they gamble their life away I don't see
the sadness I just hit like cats I see
to me I smell my thing but joy to me I
see nothing but like laughing at these
rich people that [ __ ] gambled
everything away I didn't do that but you
know the minute I roll up on Vegas what
I hear is um you know that song that
goes then yeah I don't from that era but
I just yeah yeah I just feel like a
[ __ ] like mobster yeah the minute I
roll up in Vegas just makes me feel so
bad that when we go next month we should
wear suits the entire time yeah yeah
you should be like Carmen Sandiego with
the trench coat she won this suit and
have giant hat I don't want to buy a
$5,000 suit and only gamble at the
Golden Nugget this is what I wanted to
do but they didn't they didn't want to
do it with me I was like do you guys
want to do like a tacky Vegas I'm done I
was gonna do it yeah wait you were that
I was thinking the only people that
would have appreciated was like us three
to do that every day though true but
imagine staying at the best [ __ ]
suite at the Plaza yeah the Caliph
that's sweet right scalably live like
the best king suite we're like so
imagine like I'll be at the Palms y'all
know see that's why we have to do this
we're gonna have really fun cheap things
we're gonna work on a gambling casino be
so clingy
you get your five dollar stake [ __ ]
top hat off the strip West Point
$7,000 - top hat South Point one of
those and I want to be haggling people
at the [ __ ] poker table I want to I
want to do this like gypsy royalty
that's what I wanted you know who always
gets me the people who do this and they
know how to do it like got some weight
you do now imagine you live there and
you get used to that sound thank you
good because I'm just like oh the sound
and then I'm like where's that coming
from and then I go get it